- All right, we're gonna
play Fuck, Marry, Kill.
Jeff Sessions, Sean
Spicer, and Steve Bannon.
- Jesus Christ.
- I only get to fuck one,
marry one, kill one.
- Right.
- All of them if I'm
involved are bad.
They're all punishments.
- Okay.
- Marrying me is way
worse than dying.
- For me that would just
be a fuck, fuck, fuck.
- You can always fuck
the one you killed.
- First I would get a horribly
sexually transmitted disease
and then I would
fuck Sean Spicer.
- What I'd do is I actually
make a human centipede first.
And I feel like Spicer
has to be at the front.
- Right, he's the
representative.
- He's gotta be the face.
And Sessions in the middle
just going (groaning).
- Oh, good point.
- I feel like Bannon
hasn't been working out.
Here's the great thing
about these three,
me putting 'em in
a human centipede.
I could catch any one of them.
- That's true.
- I'm spry.
I go to yoga and stuff.
Once I've made them
into a human centipede,
they're basically my bride,
they're going to die.
- That's true.
- And I'm not gonna keep
a human centipede around
and not fuck it.
- That's real.
- Like, what are we doing?
- That's half the point.
- What is this human
centipede doing?
It's to look at?
(laughing)